the massive wall of ice cut residents  completely by surprise a natural  phenomenon no one saw coming  bang the ice cream right through the  living room here  he said grab your purse grab whatever  you can get the keys  we got to get out of here two years  after floods hit the area the community  is dealing with more destruction really  I don't think I want to live here  anymore miraculously no one was injured  but the freak of nature destroyed a  dozen lakefront homes and cottages  witnesses estimate the wave was nine  meters high whipped up by strong winds  of over 80 kilometers an hour that swept  across to fajn Lake and now residents  are picking up the pieces